how much sobriety do you have now uh i
stopped drinking uh
what is it now
2011. okay so it's been it's been a
while it's been a while and like
i i was talking about this the other day
i was talking to somebody and i was like
you know i thought i'd be
the girl to like die with a cocktail in
my hand like that was my plan well my
plan was to be done by 30. i didn't
think i'd see my 30th birthday me either
and that was
the way i lived you know i was like [ __ ]
it none of this matters
just go as hard as you can and like the
fact that i made it out of the
situations that i often put myself in
in one piece uh is
pretty remarkable
i count my blessings for sure
um
but yeah i i you know i didn't think i'd
see my 30th birthday so like i'm 39 now
and i'm like wow
extra you know
what was the rock bottom for you
you know i don't know that there was
like
but the last day the last day were you
just like i gotta get help um
you know it was interesting i i actually
stopped drinking and and
using like
a couple years before my sprite it was
like 2009.
but i had relapsed after i got in a car
accident and i was using um muscle
relaxers because i broke my arm and
really [ __ ] up my neck and all that
and i just started taking
like
two three selmas at a time and it was a
really short
it was
jesus christ i was i think i wound and i
i'm pretty sure i've talked about this
before but like i wound up at swingers
the diner swingers like trying to hold a
fork and i was just like uh my friend
was there like what's wrong
you know and she's sober she was like
dude and i it had been
i don't know maybe a month not even like
it was a very short
time from like
i was using them and then using them
inappropriately and then it was like i
just can't do this anymore those things
killed people they do i remember my
doctor
if you drank on soma like you might just
not wake up drink on somas also if you
detox suddenly off of them yeah they can
cause really gnarly seizures and all
that i mean i i worked in treatment for
uh a while before coming back to fuller
house i worked in treatment for like
five or six years wow and uh yeah i
remember you know that was the thing
that i learned i was like oh
glad i didn't die that's right yeah wow
um and you don't hear about somas
anymore it's like they kind of went away
they went i mean they went away
i mean i think it's also it's like so
not something in my
i'm i'm sure
if i you know asked i'm sure i could
find them but like it's so not even in
my realm like
that anymore um
working in recovery did you ever hear
that
like statistically
the
the jobs that
people have the highest rate of relapse
are jobs where they work in recovery
yeah it's a it's
one of the most stressful things i've
ever done you know i was a
i worked uh i started as a tech and then
worked my way up and um was a director
of operations for a while and so i
oversaw you know a staff of like 120
people and a bunch of different houses
and like
you know oftentimes you're hiring people
that have been there for a year and then
they're moving out and they want to you
know so i think that's part of it too is
a lot of people even if they have a you
know the year requirement
um
it's hard and it's it's a hard
environment to work in it's there's a
huge burnout rate
um my boyfriend now is a social worker
and has his master's
uh and you know works as a case manager
and social worker and therapist and all
of that and it is it's hard you're my
best friend's a therapist she takes on
people's [ __ ] all day long right and
it's hard
you know
it's a lot but i loved i did love it i
was very fortunate in that
i went into the world of recovery and
kind of threw myself in i was making 10
bucks an hour as a tech for a while and
right
emptying trash cans and i was like
okay this is just what it is and i was
fine with that
um
but it's you know it's a lot to take on
because you care about these people and
it's getting sober's not easy and it's
not pretty right it also i think
feels pretty slippery to
put your recovery out there like
publicly like i know i i did that in a
big way right and at a certain point
like i really kind of tried to
back off of that a lot yeah i do too
like i don't talk about it as often
anymore like
it's just something that i'm like it you
know it's not all that i am and i know
people are like always fascinated by
like
you know like what was the worst point
like i don't know it was all
i had fun and then there were moments
that i like wound up in the hospital you
know with acute alcohol poisoning or
something or i wound up you know like
pass out on a sidewalk for hours and my
friends couldn't get me up or like you
know there was a lot of shitty times but
there was
fun times too but then it just became
more shitty times than good times and
then it was like now did you have fun
the last four years of of me using like
i i didn't have fun once yeah i was
positive that i was having a blast right
right but were you ready
my god it was constant just constantly
[ __ ] up everything i thought i was
so cool i thought that like i was having
the greatest time
and like every once in a while like
that wasn't the case
but like actually all the time i was
awful um
when i had kids that really changed it
for me like i
after
i had zoe my my older daughter um
i was trying to get sober again you know
i had quit drinking when i was pregnant
and then it was like she was born and i
was like
i mean i went from [ __ ] partying to
being a mom and i didn't i didn't know
what the [ __ ] i was doing it was
terrifying and
i started drinking again and then it was
like i've got to get sober but i will
say
that was the point in my life that i
really
dealt with the huge resentment of being
adopted and of my mom not being able to
get her [ __ ] together enough
like my my biological mom i think i
always held on to that resentment like
was it me
why why didn't why wasn't i good enough
why wasn't i
so you know why couldn't i change you
and i think when i got to the point
after i had my daughter and i was
struggling to get sober and quit
drinking and all of a sudden i realized
i was like
oh [ __ ]
this has nothing to do with her
this is my
sickness and my addiction issue that i
have to deal with
and suddenly it was like i understood
who
that my biological mother was and and
that she actually did
the best thing she could for me and that
it how sad that she couldn't get it
you know what i mean and it just it gave
me a different perspective on it having
gone through it myself i suddenly saw
her in a whole new way and this huge
amount of
forgiveness
came about and that was really
that
was
you know when i could drinking that was
it like i hadn't had a drink since then
um you know and again like i said i
relapsed on the other stuff but
i hadn't had a drink since then you know
and
um
it was
i i that was what i needed you know that
was a resentment that i didn't know how
to heal until i was in it it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude